the way he gets to clarice is he finds
out what the one thing
about her that the one thing that could
repulse her about herself more than
anything else
and i think in some ways it was pity
that he could look at her and say
you know i feel really sorry for you
and ultimately that that got her much
more than going ah
do you know what you look like to me
with your good bag and your cheap shoes
you look like a robe a well-scrubbed
hustling robe
with a little taste he wasn't going to
penetrate her by being a
monster in the app you know in the in
the literal way he had to
find out what it is about this
particular woman
that she didn't even know she hated
about herself
jack crawford sent a trainee to me
yes i'm a student i'm here to learn from
you
maybe you can decide for yourself
whether or not i'm qualified enough to
do that
the motivation for that certainly is
ambition there's something that she
wants from him
and she knows that to remain completely
distanced
and only to follow the rules uh won't
get her that thing
that there has to be a certain kind of
intimacy and uh
you know the reason that he allows her
that kind of intimacy is that they have
um they have respect for each other that
they they
both cherish this idea of dignity and uh
that is very much a part of both of
their personalities this need for
dignity for human
human respect and human contact in some
ways they become
uh completely um confused with each you
know they're completely intimate with
each other
most serial killers keep some sort of
trophies from their victims
i didn't no no you ate yuri
she's a woman who uses her wits and her
sensitivity and her perspicacity
and emotions and vulnerability and a
past that
in some ways is historically negative
somebody who is
relentlessly five foot four it's the
head and the heart that combat the
villain
and i can't think of any other
more perfect feminine prototype
for the woman who fights to save women
and
everything else in the film supports
that idea i tell you things you tell me
things
not about this case though about
yourself but pro quo
yes or no
yes and out there is one of the through
lines and certainly the reason why i got
involved in it was not because it was
scary you know
uh which it is the relationship between
lecter and clarice is
phenomenal it's something you've never
seen before and certainly something
you've never experienced before as an
audience
she travels through this sort of forest
of experience where she
meets gnomes and demons along the way
and has to
lay claim to and admit her fears and in
some ways come to terms with the past
come to terms with fears like fear of
mediocrity
fear of commonness she meets the villain
and uh by virtue of combining the head
and the heart
by combining what is learned and what is
experienced by combining things that you
can explain and things that are about
instinct
combats the villain and has a duel and
wins
if anything is the perfect mythic
structure
of folktale this is it
you